[Music]  your waking world is shaped  by dreams  dreams  and nightmares that i create  and which i must control  he's out there looking for me  his name  can you imagine the damage he could do  i need your help if dreams disappear  then so will humanity you could do  without dreams for a while i haven't had  a decent night's sleep in ages  i'm not going to stop  until i've reshaped this world  tell us  what power of dreams  [Applause]  i thought about giving up  but i have a job to do when i do it  things have changed  your eyes will tell me everything  every thought every feeling  [Music]  my creations do not walk amongst the  living killing mortals for pleasure  oh you don't think dreams can die  let's find out  nightmares do not belong in the waking  world  oh turns out i fit right in  dreams don't die  mr sandman  bring me a dream  [Music]  you